upbringing could they have done anything
for you to not not have pursued this
career your parents yes i uh i don't
blame it anybody's home it's all mine
but my father was an alcoholic okay and
we lived in a nice white house on a
pretty big farm but he was drunk
and he loved us and nothing wrong with
him he was just a gentleman but my poor
mother worked in the sewing factory and
dug like crazy in the dirt and
and made us helped us make a living
and i think if he had to put his arm
around me and said son you know you're
smart why don't you be this or that or a
lawyer or a doctor or whatever
i would have perked right up because
whatever he said
i like to do it but he said roger's the
best damn hog catcher in the county well
i was sure i was
i'd wrestle a bull down or ride a
bucking horse and i mean he laughed
about that and and i liked it so i just
wondered my daughter's a doctor and i
encouraged her you know what do you
listen you go for something you can do
it
so i i think well he never beat you up
he never did anything no he wasn't he
wasn't like he was abusive he just drank
he was a wonderful human being i if i
talked about him now i'd
cry but you were seeking his approval
meaning if he told if he told you to do
something positive in your life you
would have done that oh yes of course i
would have been power of a father yeah
however
can you can you go a little bit more
deeper on that the power of a father on
the son why is that rule so important
what it is it's in bread in us what our
fathers and mothers think of us it
really is particular boys with their
father
i mean i can remember things that he did
and it just warms my heart when i was
about five or six years old i'd follow
him and he we had two bird dogs and he
would shoot the quail with the double
barrel shotgun and they'd point them and
then they'd fly and pow
pow and the birds with feather was
falling the dogs would get them and come
here and then i said daddy can i shoot
that gun you know and he
he says do you really want to shoot this
12-gauge shotgun i just little
yeah i want to shoot it so he puts it
over a stump and he gets behind me real
close and holds me and he puts it in my
shoulder and he pointed to that tree and
i pulled that trigger and the bark flies
off of that pine tree man i could have
walked on the air i was so big you know
stuff like that it just uh do you
remember that vividly vividly
i remember me out in the yard and i'm
throwing a butcher knife up at the
leather wing bats i think i'm going to
hit them because they'll dive towards
you they're blind and they go away and i
see him coming down the road with his
leather coat on and a double barrel
shotgun over and his two big rabbits
hanging in i run all the way out and
meet him can i carry one and i have to
hold it up like this and the rabbit's
hair you know you just remember things
like that and and
and then for him being drunk if he would
have been carried on with that what
would i have been i would i wouldn't i'd
have never went to prison but it's
certainly not his fault it's mine i
didn't
my brother didn't go to prison my
children my sisters didn't
so you don't put any of the onus by the
what month's birthday january the 26th
aquarius wow and then how about your dad
uh
april april
pat this is something that you're
you constantly are kind of bringing up
the role of the father the role of
the role that you play with your kids
the important role that your father has
played in your life yeah something that
even when roger over here is talking
about his dad this is something that
interests you greatly like he said he's
going to get emotional this
even with um
with uh rick macy we talked about the
role of a coach and the role of a parent
the role of a father what is it about i
mean other than the obvious of obviously
your parents are important what why is
this something you keep bringing on
harping about yeah i i i just think you
know
um
you know we're trying to fix
you you're getting to the product late
to fix it
you know i don't know how to describe
that like
we're trying to fix the product after
it's already been broken for 18 years
amen instead let's work on the
most important example and
you know
face of what that product is looking up
to and who is emotionally listen
i i you know i have a lot of influence
okay so i went to um a wedding you know
with this this uh one of our guys
george's wedding
and his dad and i we've had a lot of
good battles back and forth a lot of
them over the years dad was a man's man
just like
he was a guy cuban guy you know tough
guy you know confident swagger walks in
not afraid i took him to kentucky there
every one time
and you would have thought he owned the
derby how he was and this was like 10
years ago when i took him to the derby
and 11 years ago when i took him to the
derby but he would be like why are you
making my son do this you're making him
drive from palmdale to this and papa we
would get into it i'm like listen
i'm not trying to do anything about your
son trying to help your son be a man and
a leader let me do my part let me do my
part right
and
son george is a quality quality guy very
quality guy right smart guy very success
he runs a 30 million dollar your
business with us right now does very
well for himself
but uh
he wanted to win for his dad right
and his dad comes up to me to the
wedding in november when he got me i'm
here i think november 13 or something
like that i'm in a beautiful wedding
small wedding but a beautiful wedding
and my dad's i got to talk to pat i got
to talk to him we go in the corner says
hey listen to me you need to know this
you need to hear from me because there's
only one man that can tell you this i
said what's that he says my son's had
two fathers me and you we've
raised this boy together i got him in
the first half you got him in the second
half but it's you and i and he's crying
i'm crying
my body's got chills all over you know
i'm feeling it right now
but a
boy wants to make his dad and his mom
proud and some of that [ __ ] breaks he
just i don't know so yeah to me
i would much rather train the trainers i
would much rather get the parents i
would much rather get the fathers then
we get them at this point of the game
it's too late absolutely it's too late
what are we gonna do in here at this
point so we screwed the whole thing up
way too late well
i'll tell you how to do it
let's have from starting off that's how
family planning is a great great part of
the education
did you know that there's a half a
million children in foster care and i
don't how many in in orphanages and
millions aborted every year
but
those children are unwanted no one loved
and they wind up there
a great portion of them don't know who
their parents are don't know my mama
didn't want me
and and i think i told this before my
daughter was
my daughter's a doctor and she delivered
a baby to a 10 year old child what in
the world i mean what
what four four or five generations in
the in the vision room all on welfare
and i say that a bird builds a nest
before she lays an egg not so human
beings and where the children are
are are rather more scarce
they're wanted and they're loved and
they're taken care of and nurtured and
that's what needs to be done
you know the four things i tell my kids
is lead respect improve love
yeah and and uh i i don't know
i don't know a a co-op listen everybody
talks about it's not like but it's not
like the way you sell it i don't think
the power of love man that love is a
very very
uh you know challenging thing
unfortunately we had paul manafort here
last week i don't know if you know what
paul manafort is paul manafort went to
jail trump you know that whole situation
as a lobbyist trump's campaign yeah and
i'm not i'm not a fan of lobbyists at
all and i told him i'm not offended a
lot about what these guys do right it's
a big business model you make a lot of
money but then he said something he says
what are you going to do okay don't have
lobbyists the other side's going to have
lobbyists so don't go and have them so
now what are you going to do and you're
cornered
so yeah oh you know what we're not going
to use tanks but they're going to use
tanks okay let's get a couple tanks guys
you see what i'm saying hey hey they're
going to use
rocket launchers no no that's not our
policy no we got to get rocket launchers
guys let's go buy some rocket launchers
right so eventually
to go against an enemy that's doing that
you know you you you try to use love as
much as possible but some people are
just they're playing by different rules
than you so
you as a human being are conflict
conflicted constantly conflicted to say
what should we
use to handle this crisis okay should we
handle it you know just let it go and
don't worry about it well then if you
let it go on the market gets a
reputation of you just let things go
then they're going to come in like
vultures you know take advantage of you
constantly then what do you do
and maybe that's not the responsibility
of everybody maybe that is the
responsibility to parents to impose that
love and respect and strength and
confidence on the right values and
principles and hoping the kids are going
to pick it up and do something with it
you still got a risk because at the end
of the day i think the kids got to do
what they got to do there's a lot of
kids that were raised to great parents
that did some dumb [ __ ] they did some
stupid things so a part of the onus is
going to be on them as well you can do
everything right and still screw it up
because
you are not seven and a half billion
people around your kids and you're not
around them 100 you know percent of the
time you only run them for a few
hours or minutes or sometimes they're
gone away from you when they're adults
but yeah i think uh
adam to go back to it man
um
i think somehow someway
as much as we are doing what we're doing
with parents you know with kids
i think there's got to be some kind of a
parents once a week once a month course
teaching something
i don't know because if you do it and
they do it the kids feel it
if you pick something up and somebody
tells you here's how i raise my kids and
you do it your kid is going to be the
beneficiary of what you picked up from
another person that taught it to you i
think we're not spending enough time
teaching parents i want to keep saying
this i think we're not spending enough
time teaching parents but i think you
know parents are also starting to
realize a few different things with all
the stuff that's going on disney netflix
politics you know all this mess that's
going on parents are starting to realize
uh i have to be more involved there's
four things we came up with today one of
them is they're going to start putting
their kids in more private schools
because right values and principles are
necessary number two is homeschooling is
going to increase number three is
they're going to relocate to different
places could be a state they're going to
relocate to a different place and number
four i'm going to keep saying this to
you and i'm not even in the business i'm
telling you right now
you're going to see
more
parents putting kids in churches
some kind of addition like like mma my
kids go to the bar here in fort
lauderdale
and
i got to tell you they're sitting there
teaching them discipline that's not how
you do this you respect each other you
do this you have to put your kids in
communities right now that are teaching
the right values and principles whether
it's martial arts whether it's church
whether it's sports whether it's
anything
because there's a lot of it's almost as
if there's a lot of people that are also
confusing kids nowadays where parenting
matters and supporting cast matters so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]